at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by wealth front and this is a very
unique sponsor wealth front is a
massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free
exactly the portfolio they put you in
and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself
you can do that or as I would you can
set it and forget it and here's why the
value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show
because I use them and recommend them in
this case it's a little different I
don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront com forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront Inc is
an SEC registered investment advisor
investing in securities involves risks
and there is the possibility of losing
money past performance is no guarantee
of future results please visit wealth
front comm to read their full disclosure
so check it out guys this is one of the
hottest most innovative companies coming
out of Silicon Valley and they're
killing it they've become massively
popular just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
and my answer is inevitably athletic
greens it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out it's
tasty but more important it will help
you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind puts a lot in my body and check it
out athletic greens calm forward-slash
Tim how's Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out their routines
habits favorite books etc that you can
apply to your own life this time around
we have an in-between ax so it's not
really in between a suit it is an
experimental Q&A episode with navall
rava kott the first episode we did with
navall was a massive massive success it
was nominated for podcast of the year
navall at navall and AV al on twitter is
the CEO and co-founder of angel list
he previously co-founded opinions which
went public as part of shopping.com and
vast com he is an active angel investor
a good buddy of mine
and has invested in more than 100
companies including quite a few unicorn
mega successes his deals include Twitter
uber Yammer post mate swish thumbtack
and Open DNS Open DNS was recently
bought by Cisco for around six hundred
and thirty five million dollars in cash
so he's doing all right and he has
developed an incredibly diverse set of
skills and even if you have zero
interest in startups or investing this
episode just like the one before it is
well worth the listen navall answers
your questions the top 10 questions that
were submitted and uploaded on reddit
and that ranges from art of
intelligence and his thoughts on the
pros and cons the bull side of the bear
side if that makes any sense to money
making very practical pragmatic Silicon
Valley or non Silicon Valley money
making success what he would teach in
school favorite books what is on his
Kindle as we speak his most popular
tweet of all time and the story behind
it the five chimps theory and how it
applies to your life happiness hacks
conflict resolution the list goes on and
on so say hello to Duvall on Twitter let
him know what you thought ask additional
questions at navall nav al and please
enjoy this incredibly fascinating
monologue with navall rava cod hello
everybody and welcome to the tim ferriss
show this is Nevada rabbit hunt I will
be now going through a large set of
questions
Andrew bliss asks what are your thoughts
on the AI industry which seems to be
dominated by an unusual amount of
analytic startups most of which do the
same thing in an anti zero to one
fashion yeah so artificial intelligence
is all the rage and people are writing
books about and talking about I'm
thinking about it I think anybody who is
really talking about true
general-purpose AI the Skynet kind
that'll take over the world and kill us
all
doesn't really write code much anymore
because no one has yet made any of the
fundamental breakthroughs required to
get to where the general-purpose AI
we're just basically making writing
similar code to what we're written in
the past but it's being executed faster
or it's working with more data but the
way in which the human brain works is
actually very different than the way
computers work and I don't think the
fundamental theoretical breakthroughs
are in place for a general-purpose a I
so I think it's mostly technophiles or
end-of-the-world types or wishful
thinking in a weird way for people who
think we're about to get a
general-purpose AI that said the field
of AI has now broadened into specific AI
so computer vision for example
self-driving cars drones that pilots
themselves these things are real and
they're using huge amounts of data
as well as lots of processing power plus
pretty good code to solve problems that
before we would have thought are in the
human domain but the real test for AI is
passing the Turing test which is can you
trick someone can an AI trick so into
thinking that they're actually human
being and I think we are actually barely
any closer to that than we were twenty
or thirty years ago now there's another
kind of AI that might emerge which might
be an emergent AI for example if you
take all the computers in the world you
stitched them together say through the
internet it could just happen that that
much compute power that much data that
much interaction could create something
almost socially out of that computer
network a social AI if you will but an
AI like that is likely to be slowly
softly emergent probably not self
modifying in the way we think of a
general AI and one that's probably more
designed to serve humans because it
emerges from a network that is built by
humans or it may also just coexist or be
completely woven into the human fabric
in such a way that it might be
inseparable from humanity itself so I'm
not too worried about the general
purpose AI and I also don't think that
the general AI general-purpose AI
companies have have much of a future but
the specific AI companies the ones that
are solving a very specific problem like
the computer vision example those I
think could be very real
Taylor Pearson asks you mentioned Kouzes
1937 paper in your first interview and
how Tech is bringing down the
transaction cost and led to corporatism
what do you think the job and labor
market will look like in 20 years and
how can people prepare well I mentioned
in the first interview that the
Industrial Revolution sort of brought
people together because a minimum
efficient scale to do something
especially with a factory was very large
so you need to have a hierarchy you need
to have people working for each other
and working together now I think
information technology is lowering the
communication cost lowering transaction
costs and people can be intermediate had
already been disintermediated by
computers and work through computers so
though you know a not-so-great example
is an uber driver who would be getting
orders through the
through a phone but a better example a
more hopeful example might be
independent contractors or using Twitter
and online sources to find jobs or you
know AngelList we have tons of startup
jobs or they're places like pic crew or
gigster where you can go and get
part-time jobs Elance craigslist oDesk
etc so I think that gig economy is gonna
be much more of the future and it can
actually be a very positive development
for example if you were a great
journalist today if you're a world-class
journalist you take great photographs
you report great news you don't really
need to go work for the New York Times
if you are willing to start in your
spare time with a blog with Twitter you
can build an independent brand and
although you must start off making no
money early on kind of near the end of
the career when you're a YouTube star or
a blog or a very popular blogger you can
literally be charging people for access
to your blog and you can be making a
very good and very independent living
where you're getting paid for books and
newsletters and working from wherever
you want
so I think the best way to prepare for
the future 20 years is find something
you love to do so you have a shot at
being one of the best people in the
world at it build an independent brand
around it with your name not with a
company's name or with other people's
names around it try to make a creative
work so you'll stay interesting you'll
stay ahead of the game anything that's
not creative society can replicate and
then not pay you full value over time so
it's better to always solve new problems
and do new things and get comfortable
with working in a boom-bust fashion
where a couple of weeks at a time you
may have a lot of work and then a couple
of weeks at a time you're on vacation so
I think that's kind of where the future
is headed it'll be gradual and then
it'll be sudden but the best way to
prepare is to just not give up your
independence in the first place char's
audiences Confucius says that you have
two lives and the second one begins when
you realize you only have one when and
how did your second life begin it's a
very deep question I think most people
who are past a certain age have had this
feeling or phenomenon where they've gone
through most of life a certain way and
and got into a certain stage and then
had to make some pretty big changes and
I'm definitely also in that boat I think
for me it was I struggle for a lot of my
life to have certain material and social
successes and when I achieved those
material and social successes or at
least beyond the point where they didn't
matter as much to me anymore
I realized that my peer group and a lot
of the people who were around me and the
people who had achieved the similar
successes and were on their way to
achieving more and more successes just
didn't seem all that happy and and in my
case there was definitely hedonic
adaptation I'd very quickly get used to
anything so let me to the conclusion
which seems trite that happiness is
internal and so then that set me on a
path of starting to work more on my
internal self and realizing that all
real success is internal and has very
little to do with external circumstances
but one has to do the external thing
anyway that's how you're biologically
hardwired so it's it's glib to say you
can just turn it off you have to do it
and you have to have your own life
experience that then brings you back on
to the internal path so for me it was
just basically getting what I wanted was
the problem very related to that Daniel
D 161 asks do you feel an inner urge to
know yourself fully and has your worldly
success satisfied this urge I would say
yeah I absolutely do have an inner urge
to know myself fully and if anything the
worldly success has taken has has taken
me further away from satisfying that
urge the more worldly success you have
the more your ego gets built up the more
fearful you might be of losing it all
the more you care what other people
think the more you have to lose the more
you get caught up in this dream of who
you think you are and so I think worldly
success actually hurts if if from a
young age you know that you want to know
yourself and discover yourself much
better if you have that foresight or
insight at an early age then material
success will actually take you away from
it
I'm not Christian but there is that
famous line in the Bible that you know
Jesus is easier than you know a camel to
go through the eye of a needle than for
a rich man to get into heaven and I
think I understand what he means
Rasputin 89 says in the first episode
navall talked about a few topics that
should be taught in school rather than
learning the capital on Montana he
brought up topics like teaching what he
knows that work for him and Happiness
nutrition etc can you ask him to
elaborate in some of these particularly
happiness yeah I mean if I'm running a
grade school curriculum for children I
would probably optimize happiness
nutrition diet exercise how do you build
good habits how do you break bad habits
how do you have good relationships how
do you find your spouse meditation how
do you build basic skills and not
memorize lots of facts what kinds of
books should you read preferably older
ones not newer ones that have withstood
the test of time I probably have them
run a lemonade stand or a small business
and you know earn money and so they can
understand how that works probably have
them work on something charitable
related or take them to the third world
and show them suffering true suffering
so they can get some context prior teach
them public speaking business writing
basic persuasion maybe a little bit of
programming on top of the reading
writing and arithmetic I probably
eliminate chunks of geography history
maybe honestly even second and third
languages music unless they have musical
inclinations and I know this is going to
horrify some people but the time has to
come from somewhere so the question is
what do you emphasize so I think it's
not necessarily good to educate every
child in everything you have to find out
what their aptitude is for and what's
more practical and we're now living in
the Wikipedia era we're living in the
internet era so a lot of the factual
memorization that used to go on is now
completely irrelevant you can just look
it up so those kinds of things I think
need to go away I mean think about the
fact that if you have young children
right now or you're planning on having
children that your children probably
will not need to know how to drive a car
so there's all kinds of time savings to
be had and it can be used for these
other things the happiness one is a very
complex topic
I actually don't think happiness is its
own thing I think a lot of what we think
of as happiness is actually this
pleasure it's physical pleasure either
from oh that tasted good or it might be
momentary pleasure from oh she loves me
or he loves me but I think true
happiness comes out of peace and peace
comes out of many things but it comes
out of fundamentally understanding
yourself it comes from looking inside
yourself and understanding how much of
what you're reacting to our emotional
reactions or attachment is
self-inflicted suffering its desired
that you have four things that you
probably shouldn't care that much about
there's a great line that my brother
Kamal quoted in his book here's a great
book called love yourself like you know
like your life depends on it and another
one called live your truth he's actually
the philosopher in the family I'm just
yea mature but he had a great line in
there where he said I once asked him a
monk you know what what is your secret
to to peace and happiness and the monk
said I say yes to everything that
happens I say yes and that's very hard
for us to imagine because in life we're
used to fighting for everything we used
to getting whatever you want we're used
to reacting we're used to immediately
saying that stinks that's good that's
bad we're used to constantly judging
things and the act of judging something
separates you from that thing and over
time as you judge that judge you
invariably judge people you judge
yourself you separate yourself from
everything and then you end up only and
that feeling of disconnection and
loneliness is what eventually leads to
suffering and then you struggle you
resist against the world the way it is
and that that is what your ego does it
helps you operate in the real world by
resistant against against things you
don't like and that is a source also of
a lot of unhappiness so I actually think
happiness is the absence of suffering it
comes from peace and that comes from
just being very careful about desired
judgment and reactions realizing that
you don't really need something anymore
that that that something is not
important to you so to get very
practical about it I have a whole series
of tricks that I use to try and be
happier in the moment and I started
doing these a few years ago
at first they were silly and difficult
and required a lot of attention but now
some of them have become second nature
and I think doing them I've just
religiously I've managed to increase my
happiness level quite a bit the obvious
one is meditation and Insight Meditation
so working towards a specific purpose on
it which is to try and understand how my
mind works but then just being very
aware in every moment so if I catch
myself judging somebody then I can stop
myself and say well what's the positive
interpretation of this so I used to get
annoyed about things now I always look
for the positive side of it and it used
to take a rational effort used to take a
few seconds for me to come up with a
positive now I can do it sub-second my
brain is trained to do it automatically
similarly I try you know there are other
hacks I could try to get more sunlight
on my skin that's an easy cheap one look
up and smile tell yourself tell your
friends that you're a happy person then
you'll be forced to be to conform to it
you'll have the consistency bias you
have to live up to it your friends will
expect you to be a happy person
these are little hacks I mean they add
up over time they're not gonna pull you
out of a severe depression that's a much
deeper more difficult thing but if
you're just trying to upgrade your
happiness ever so slightly you can do it
another hack would be just any time you
catch yourself desiring something say is
it really that important to me that I'd
be unhappy unless this goes my way and
you're gonna find the vast majority of
things it's just not true
I think I'm dropping caffeine made me
happier it made me more of a stable
person working out everyday makes me
happier if you have peace of body you
have it's much easier to have peace of
mind so there's there's lots and lots of
these things that can go on this could
be a full podcast but I'm still
discovering and learning these things
myself I think it would be interesting
to maybe catalogue them but I suspect
that a lot of them are deeply deeply
personal if I step back for a second and
answer the question properly the most
important trick I think to being happy
is to realize that happiness is a skill
that you develop and a choice that you
make you choose to be happy
and then you work at it it's just like
building muscles is just like losing
weight it's just like succeeding at your
job it's just like learning calculus you
decide it's important to you you
prioritize it above everything else you
read everything on the topic and then
you work at it and again I think the
Buddhists have done a lot of good work
on this
I don't think modern science has good
answers here I think the modern world is
actually really bad the modern world is
full of distractions things like Twitter
and Facebook are not making you happy
they're actually making you unhappy
you're essentially playing a game that's
created by the creators of those systems
and yes it can be a useful game once in
a blue moon but most of the time you're
just wasting your time you're engaging
in envy dispute and the resentment
comparision jealousy anger about things
that frankly just don't matter the
refined man asks how do you tend to
handle conflict when it arises I handle
conflict very poorly I get angry I'm an
angry person so I have to catch myself
in the moment and I have to talk myself
down I have to recognize the anger for
what it is I have to sense the bodily
reactions and then I have to see if I
can stay calm and usually throw you're
hard for me it's my nature to try and
solve a problem the moment arises I
don't do well with long term stress
where it is an unsolved problem hanging
out there probably the single best piece
of advice I can give other than being
mindful and just aware when you're
engaging in conflict is to not associate
with high conflict people when someone
is when we all know people in our lives
who just tend to get a little more angry
a little more judgmental or they're
always in a fight with somebody else if
you see someone who's always fighting
with somebody else they're eventually
gonna fight with you
so I have just slowly cut those people
out of my life not in an overt explicit
way but just by choosing to hang out
with them less and less there are plenty
of smart successful kind and happy
people in the world and you just have to
make space for them in your life by
letting the people who still have
lessons to learn drift off and go learn
their lessons it's not your job to
educate them sometimes very unhappy
people
all sort of have this air about them
like a drowning person where they're
thrashing and making a big ruckus but if
you if you grab them and try to save
them unless you're an extremely happy
person yourself you're gonna drown too
so I would say the first rule of of
handling conflict is don't hang around
people who were constantly engaging in
conflict what insight about life have
you acquired that seems obvious to you
but might not be obvious to everybody
else this is a tough one it's a deep
question I do have one fundamental
recent belief that have acquired the
last few years that I don't think most
people would agree with but it's such a
personal thing and it came about in such
personal circumstances that I'm not sure
anybody else will get there in the same
line of reasoning that said I'll lay it
out anyway which is I'm not afraid of
death anymore and I think a lot of the
struggle that we have in life
comes from a deep deep fear of death and
it can take it's it can take form in
many ways one can be that you know we
want to write the Great American Novel
or we really want to achieve something
that this will build something we want
to you know build a great piece of
technology or let's start an amazing
business or we want to run for office
and make a difference and a lot of that
just comes from sort of this fear that
we're gonna die so we have to build
something that lasts beyond us obviously
also the obsession that parents have
with their children I mean a lot of that
is warrant in biological love but some
of that is also the quest for
immortality even some of the beliefs are
some of the more outlandish parts of
organized religion I think fall into
that and I don't have that quest for
immortality anymore and I think I came
to this fundamental conclusion I thought
about it a lot and we've been the
universe has been around for a long time
the universe is a very very large place
if you study even the smallest bit of
science you realize that for all
practical purposes we are nothing we're
we're like we are amoeba we're bacteria
to the universe we were basically
monkeys on a small rock orbiting a small
kourt's star in a huge galaxy which is
in an absolutely staggering a gigantic
universe which is self may be part of a
gigantic multiverse and this universe
has been around probably for ten billion
years or more and will be around for
tens of billions of years afterwards so
your existence my existence is is just
impetus amo it's like a firefly blinking
once in the night so we're not really
here very long and we don't really
matter that much and nothing that we do
lasts so eventually you will fade your
works will fade your children will fade
your thoughts will fade this planet will
fade the Sun will fade it'll all be gone
their entire civilizations that we just
remember now with one or two words like
Sumerian or Mayan you know do you know
any Sumerians or Mayans do you hold any
of them in high regard or steam have
they outlived their natural lifespan
somehow no so I think we're just here
for an extremely short period of time
now from here you can choose to believe
in an afterlife or not and if you really
do believe in an afterlife then that
should give you comfort and make you
realize that maybe you know everything
that goes on this life is not that
consequential on the other hand if you
don't believe in an afterlife then you
should also come to a similar conclusion
where you should realize that this is
such a short and precious life that it's
really important that you don't spend it
being unhappy there's no excuse for
spending most of your life in misery
you've only got 70 years out of the 50
billion or so the universe still be
around and whatever your natural state
is it's probably not this this is your
living state your dead state it's true
over a much longer time frame so when I
think about the world that way I sort of
realized that it's just kind of a game
which is not to say that you go to a
dark place and you start acting
unethically and immorally quite the
contrary you realize just how precious
life is and how it's important to make
sure that you enjoy yourself you sleep
well at night
you're a good moral person you're
generally happy you take care of other
people you help out but you can't take
it too seriously you can't get too hung
up over it you can't make yourself
miserable or I'm happy over it you just
have a very short period
here on this earth nothing you do is
gonna matter that much in the long run
don't take yourself so seriously and
then that just kind of helps make
everything else work so yeah that's
that's an insight about life that I've
acquired that now seems obvious to me
but it's really not I think obvious to
most people related to that predict
Steven asks what's your philosophy of
life or grand goal and living in other
words of the things in life you might
pursue which is the thing you believe to
be most valuable another great question
I think before when I had the usual
quest for immortality fear that almost
all of us do that's coated into our
genes and that was driving me I was
trying to build lasting things create
things make money build businesses write
books that sort of thing now I realized
a lot of as meaningless that's just
stuff that keeps us busy it's
entertaining it might have some social
good it might help build this as moral
character and human beings but it's not
really the purpose of life is there a
purpose of life that's that's tough it's
a philosophy of life that's tough
I think the closest I can articulate and
I'll probably change my mind on this
next year is to keep growing and
learning in this short period of time
that you have to seek truth and to
accept things the way they are to see
the world the way it really is and then
just to live your life I think that's it
I think any deeper meanings or goals
just lead to ideologies which lead to
desires and belief systems and
disappointments and conflict it's better
just to live the life that you have on
this earth enjoy it while you go try and
see things the way they truly are not
the way you wish they were and to be in
harmony with things the way that they
are easier said than done
a number of people asked me what books
I'm reading now
and this is a very difficult question to
answer because at any given time I
probably about 50 books in my Kindle and
probably about 6 or 7 hardcover or
softcover physical books that I'm
cycling through so literally I opened up
my Kindle I look through based on my
mood I'll flip to whichever book
matches up to my mood I'll flip to
whatever part of it looks the most
interesting and I'll just read that part
so I don't read in a sequential order
and the most important thing that does
for me is it lets me just eat I'm sorry
let's me read on a regular basis and so
I can actually just pull up my kindle
here and I can read off the names of
some of these books that are reading
that can give you mini reviews but I
haven't actually finished any of them so
they're all in progress so at any given
time I was reading some science fiction
because sci-fi is always very
imaginative in terms of hypothesizing
how the world's going to work out
usually as an interesting point of view
you learn a little science so just based
on friends recommendations I've been
flipping through Greg Egan brilliant
writer physicists I believe who has
written two very hardcore sci-fi stories
so I've been reading a book from him
called distress I've always got
collections of science fiction
I finished the Martian which was decent
but I felt like it went on a little bit
too long I know it's a very popular book
with some people loved graphic novels so
I've been rereading the boys recently
which is one of my favorite graphic
novels of all time getting into kind of
the more evolution science kind of books
Matt released the evolution of
everything
I recommend everything by Matt Ridley
actually I think he's great so I really
highly highly recommend picking up a
genome the Red Queen origins of virtue
the rational optimist and the evolution
of everything that I'm reading the
essential Gandhi Mahatma Gandhi been
reading let's see I've got here the
dowel philosophy Alan Watts
I've got allusions Richard bog which I
read before but I'm flipping through
again I just like the way it's it flows
the better Procrustes aphorisms by
Nassim Taleb who's famous for the Black
Swan fool by randomness but I sort of
liked his collection of ancient wisdom
in the bed of pro Krusty's the lessons
of history by will and Ariel Durant
which was actually recommended by one of
the listeners in the first podcast great
book I really like how it summarizes
the larger themes of history very
incisive and unlike most history books
is actually really small and it covers a
lot of ground I've actually been reading
my brother's book
I just finished how to love yourself
like it yeah like your life depends on
it and I thought it was great very
simply written obviously a plug for my
bro
I was reading Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas although I think I'll put that
down
I get it but halfway through it's just a
giant drug and in skew old orgy by heart
arrest Thompson and his friends so that
it was entertaining but I sort of gave
up after a bit richard fineman been
really perfectly reasonable deviations
and also reading genius rereading genius
I'm rereading the power of myth by
Joseph Campbell sometimes I think it's
better just to reread the greats than it
is to read something you know that's not
as great in the philosophy side I've
been reading rereading the daodejing
and I just finished falling into grace
by re Ashanti which I thought was very
good
see also read some Chad McKenna recently
he's a weird one I'm not sure I'd
recommend him for everybody gods debris
by Scott Adams very interesting the
origin of consciousness and the
breakdown at the bicameral mind there's
a mouthful for you by Julian James
mastering the core teachings the buddha
by daniel ingram that's a great book
actually recommended to me by a friend
it's available online
I would I would get that one I thought
it was for if you're interested in
Buddhism meditation insight I thought
that one was a great one that brought
everything together while leaving the
mysticism out of it so I mean that's
that should give you an indication I'm
always really something about
Krishnamurti usually it's total freedom
which is the book that I just reread
over and over the most very difficult
book doesn't necessarily make sense for
everybody but when you're ready for it
there's nothing else like it I also
recently finished the power of habit
or close to finish as close as I ever
get that one was interesting not because
of its content initially but just
because it's good for me to always keep
on top of mine how powerful habits are
habits are everything humans are
basically habit machines we form habits
when we run in those habits all day long
and have it's gonna be great because
they help us get things done very
efficiently without having to reprocess
them all the time
they can also be terrible because we can
have addictions doesn't be obvious bad
habits but also they allow us to go
through our life unconsciously and
mindlessly so it's very important to be
aware of your habits and know how to
break habits and know how to make habits
and you know I have this daily workout
that I do that I think I mentioned in
the last podcast and a lot of people ask
about it I think that one is interesting
but the specific technique matters less
the most important thing is just doing
some kind of physical activity every
single day and if you can make it the
same activity at the same time because
that right there will teach you the
power of habits if you do something
seven days a week with no exceptions and
you work out early in the morning or
when you first get out then it will
automatically fix all kinds of other bad
habits that you have you can't be out
drinking late at night you can't be out
partying you can't sleep in you can't
consume too much caffeine there are all
kinds of other habits in your life that
may be bad that get fixed if you stick
to your daily workout habit and then it
teaches you what the power of a habit is
and then as you shed other bad habits
then you realize that habits can be
broken and you start breaking them so I
think learning how to break habits is
actually a very very important Metta
skill that can serve you better in life
than almost anything else and although
you can read tons of books on it and I
recommend you shouldn't go read all the
books on it the reality is you're never
going to learn how to break bad habits
until you just break them and so one
thing I try to do is I try and break a
bad habit every six months and I try and
pick up a good habit every six months to
a year and you you can't beat yourself
up too much on it but I don't think it's
too much to ask if you were to save
yourself in 2016 I'm gonna break one bad
habit I'm gonna do everything in my
power just to take down that one habit
and everything else will be static I'm
not gonna get new worse but that will
that will help move the ball forward and
then you get gradual improvements in
your life that you stick with like I
used to be a pretty overweight and I've
lost weight over the last decade where
now I feel I'm pretty fit and healthy
it hasn't come through any single big
epiphany or realization
although definitely going paleo help and
understanding low-carb helped and helped
and getting rid of processed foods
helped and all those kinds of things but
it came from it mainly came from just
habit changes and changing habits slowly
but steadily over the course of a decade
so the good news is I've almost never
slid backwards I don't and I've never
felt endanger regaining the weight that
I've lost and now at the age of 42 I'm
probably within one pound of my lightest
weight since I was an adult and I think
that just comes from having stacked down
a bunch of good habits and haven't
gotten rid of a bunch of bad habits so I
would say the power to make and break
habits learning how to do that is really
important and if you're gonna if you're
gonna leave this podcast and pick up two
skills in life I would say and it
depends on the person because many of
you I mean Tim's entire audience is a
bunch of overachievers so many of you
are way ahead of me on both of these but
for those of you who may be behind on
one of them I would say first realize
that happiness is a choice and it is a
skill and you can dedicate yourself to
learning that skill and making that
choice and telling people about it and
working on it and you can slowly but
steadily over the course of years make
yourself happier and similarly I would
say that habits are breaking habits is a
skill and it is something you can learn
and start with a small habit and tried
different techniques to break it try
substituting try going cold turkey try
weaning yourself off try social proof by
telling other people that you're gonna
break the habit try putting other habits
around it they'll leave you no time for
that habit try to remove the triggers
try toning down the rewards do whatever
it takes but break one bad habit this
year and once you pick up that skill
it's it's a beautiful thing because then
slowly you can shed all your bad habits
and make room for good habits in your
life breakout list asked a big bunch of
questions
when I answer just one of them right now
come back to yours later break how this
says what personal efficiency or life
management things do you do on a
semi-regular basis eg some kind of life
review exercise where you rate certain
categories
etc the answer is none I am lazy that
way I choose to live a spontaneous and
free life I don't want to live a very
structured life I know people who are
married friends of mine who are married
and they actually have quarterly
meetings with their wife and they have
you know reports and how are we
performing as a marriage and what our
objectives and what are our key results
and you know what's our one-year plan
what's our five-year plan and I just
don't plan I'm not a planner I prefer to
live in the moment and be free and flow
and be happy I think projecting too much
in the future judging yourself setting
yourself up in very difficult ways other
than as I talked about just like one
habit or one desire if you start trying
to control yourself on a micro basis if
you try and micromanage yourself all
you're gonna do is make yourself
miserable and you're gonna get nothing
done so just focus on the one or two
really really important things and
everything else just surrender to it
just take it as it comes just accept it
be happy with it be glad that you're in
this world be glad that you're clothed
and fed and that you're not getting
bombs dropped in your head like some
people in the world are and you know
just it's it I think it's I think I'd
like to stay free because that way I can
see the little miracles in life you know
and there are little miracles everywhere
it's just we have taken them for granted
the fact that you were in clothes the
fact that you have enough food to eat
the fact that you're in a in a place of
shelter yes you can roll your eyes about
it yes you can say yeah that's obvious
everybody has it but actually not
everybody has it it would be great to go
take a trip to a third-world country or
to a refugee camp and see how little
some other people have and I think it's
a bad habit that we developed that we
forget how to appreciate what we do have
and so not obsessing about the future
and not beating yourself up over what
you don't have is very important because
then you can actually pay attention and
be grateful for what you do have
hephæstus to ask for more book
recommendations especially any book
recommended by the listeners in the
podcast last podcast that stood out and
had an impact in your life yeah actually
the the last podcast was a treasure
trove in a comment section of good books
and you know I I recommended and I got
back even more great books so I must
have bought at least 10 or 15 books just
from the comments section and a couple
that ever had really stood out to me
I mentioned the lessons of history I
thought that was really good too soon
old too late smart that was a fun light
read and the profit by Gibran which I
had actually never read but it literally
read like a modern-day poetic religious
tome you know up there with the
bhagavad-gita the daodejing the Bible
the Koran it sort of was written in that
style where it had that feel of
religiosity and truth but it was very
approachable and beautiful and
nondenominational and non secretarial so
I really like that love that book he has
a gift for poetically describing what
children are like what lovers are like
what marriage should be like you know
how you should treat your enemies and
your friends how you should work with
money
what can you think of you know every
time to kill something to eat it how do
you deal with that so I felt like like
the great religious books it gave a very
deep very philosophical but very true
answer to how to approach the major
problems in life
I recommend the Prophet for everybody
whether you're religious or not or
whether you are Christian or Hindu and
Jewish or atheists and I think it's a
beautiful book and it's worth reading so
thank you to whoever recommended that
one now I'm gonna switch gears for a
second and in the final section is
podcast I'm gonna just focus on the
questions that are very vocational
focused it's funny I got a whole bunch
of questions that say probably about
two-thirds were about philosophy and
life and reading and learning and growth
and those are fun for me to answer
because the new feel for me myself and I
learned from it too by talking about it
and by hearing responses about it but
there's a set of questions that are very
particular about how do I make money how
do I get a good venture capitalist how
to run my company etc and I've been sort
of putting those off because to me those
are almost old hat but I'm gonna answer
those now in in this
so let me go through those I know I
covered a few those before but they're
all the remaining ones from this point
are out are very practical so if you are
more interested in the philosophical
issues or the books then this is then
we're done with that section you can
probably just stop the podcast if you
want to ever discuss any of those topics
the best way to find me is on Twitter
you can find me as at navall and AV al
and I'm usually reasonably responsive
there as long as it's not too open-ended
it's kind of an interesting conversation
so let's dive right into it the
money-making questions Vick Rush said
let's assume that you're in your late
twenties with no real money college
education you decide to begin your
journey with business and startups what
would you begin with what would you do
oh yeah and you don't live in SF well
unfortunately I'd say move to SF and if
you can't move to SF move to a startup
hub and that could include depending on
where you are in the country that could
be Austin that could be LA that could be
New York that could be in Boston that
could be brilliant that could be London
it could be Bangalore
it could be Shanghai it could be even
parts of Delhi or Beijing so
unfortunately all the other people who
are in startups are in these places so
you have to get in the flow now the good
news is once you get in the flow you're
gonna figure out if you're motivated
what to do you'll be able to maybe go to
a school where you can learn how to code
and there's tons of them around tons of
great academy like app academy and hack
reactor and general assembly does
classes where you can learn how to code
you can volunteer for startups you can
you know start up and maybe customer
service or you can start off in
operations or in you know just keeping
the office running do whatever it takes
but get into the startup scene and
startups are moved forward by people who
are just willing to do the work and you
don't necessarily have to be a genius or
I have to have a technical background
but if it won't do the work and you want
to learn and you're in the right hub
you'll you'll figure your way out within
a couple of years duet 14 says you study
computer science and economics how do
these fields impact your thinking and if
you can go back would you still pursue
the same education and why or why not I
would pursue similar I would say that
microeconomics was incredibly
useful macroeconomics was mostly useless
the part of computer science that was
very theoretical like algorithms and
mathematics is actually the most useful
because that stuff doesn't change over
time
the part that was learning to program in
Java or Fortran was used less or less
useful because it fades over time so I
would probably do more math more physics
stick to micro everything and I would
have promptly studied some psychology
and some evolution because I think those
are really important to understanding
how humans work and at the end of the
day you're interacting with humans
everywhere you go I want to focus on
theory and principles over facts because
facts phaidor facts can be looked up and
probably the most important skill is not
really even what what you major in what
you study it's just knowing how to learn
and if you have a good grasp of
mathematics and if you'd like to read
there's nothing you can't learn on your
own be tense a man asks hey Tim and
navall question from an eighteen year
old in the Philippines what advice would
you give to ambitious 18 year olds who
want to be successful in founding
startups and investing like univille ha
basically the question is how do I get
as rich as you but faster cuz nobody
wants to put in the time well as I said
before first move to a startup hub if
you're gonna be in that industry or just
go to the hub for whatever your industry
is so if you want to be an actor go to
Hollywood if you'll be in Broadway go to
New York if you want to be in finance go
to New York or London or Hong Kong
second I think Charlie Munger had a
great answer there's Charlie Munger is
Warren Buffett's right-hand man and he
gets asked these kinds of things all the
time he's a self-made multi billionaire
and very wise in his ways and I think
I'm gonna paraphrase him Mangal is
answer but you should look it up he
basically said you know you just get up
early in the morning you work really
hard you learn something every day you
put one foot in front of the other and
if you live long enough eventually you
will get what you deserve and that's it
so there's no certainty in life you can
put in the hours you can put in the time
but you can't really expect the outcome
unfortunately one of the one of the
things that investing has really taught
me it's just how much randomness there
is in the world how many
times you think you can do something
right but it still doesn't work out so I
often see that you know individual
entrepreneurial efforts often fail but
individual entrepreneurs over their
careers rarely fail as long as you can
keep taking shots on goal and you keep
getting back up eventually you'll get
through so let's just just stick at it
and although you might win early that's
rare
those stories are very very rare more
likely users have to put in the time and
people who tend to win very early in
life don't learn the right lessons they
tend to lose that money in fact I made a
small fortune when I was very young just
by being in the right combo company in
1999 and then of course I held on to it
too long and I lost the whole thing and
that was a really good lesson because it
meant that as I made a little bit of
money later in life now I knew how rare
and precious it was and I knew how to
hang on to it I didn't have the contempt
for money that comes from making it too
easily I had a deep respect for how hard
it is to make so put in the hours
practic Steven asked what advice would
you give a talented software engineer
who was at Google Facebook Microsoft
Amazon continues to work they should
they continue to work there and get
promoted should they move to an
established startup like Airbnb should
they move to an early-stage startup or
should they bootstrap a software product
or should they found to start up and
play the VC funded game and is there a
slight comfort of interest people advice
to would-be founders from investors well
yes investors giving advice is always
self-serving advice so don't take your
advice from investors and you can't help
it because they have their particular
view of the world and just realize that
incentives are everything Charlie Munger
who I mentioned earlier says incentives
or superpowers and he also said if you
could be working on incentives then you
shouldn't be working on anything else he
means like in a context of with your
employees or your product incentives are
everything that said what path should
you take heck I don't know I mean
they're all good paths
it depends what you want a lot out of
life you could try them all if you know
you want to start a company you know
what the company is and you know who you
want to do it with and you feel like you
have a good understanding of the space
and go do it you're ready on the
and if you don't know how to do it or
you don't yet know what it is then you
should probably get as close to it as
possible and that would mean joining a
startup
and if you want to be a founder then you
probably want to join a start-up that's
very early if you're more interested in
making having a good lifestyle or making
money for your family then you may want
to go to a later stage startup the one
that is more clearly on the path of
success so I think this questions like
this unfortunately don't have glib
answers there's highly highly contextual
but the fact that you're thinking about
it means you're going about it the right
way
startups are a young person's game it's
better to do them early in life before
you settle down before you have too many
obligations before you've gotten kind of
set in your ways so if you if you're
gonna do a startup you should at least
take one shot at it before you're 30 or
35 after that I find it gets a lot
harder
that's me personally though there are
plenty of great entrepreneurs who are
executing in their 40s and 50s and 60s
and I think t boone pickens who's still
an entrepreneur an operator is something
as 80s or something like that it's a
very practical question what is your
advice to those on US visas how can they
go about launching a start-up in the
value of keeping their primary job in
the short term and what communities and
incubators can they reach out to for
help and advice actually there's a
there's a great accelerator incubator
that I'm a small investor in call
unshackled I think there unshackle CO
and what they solve exactly this problem
they help great engineers designers
entrepreneurs start companies while
retaining their visa status and they
have a way to work that out that's
perfectly legal and ethical and good and
it helps immigrants create jobs and
create wealth and create products for
the rest of us
so I highly recommend checking out
unshackled and now there may be others
like it that's just the one that I
happen to be aware of Travel Vinny asks
a good question in a world where the
majority of people will guard money much
more than time how do you protect your
own time and still not offend people or
damaged relationships both
professionally and personally any
strategies are Goodreads and this you
could suggest yeah this is the bane of
my existence I get hit up for coffees
lunches meetings obligations to dues
phone calls for a little while I was a
little ornery about it and I used to own
the domain I don't do coffee comm and I
would reply to emails from an avowal
that I don't do coffee calm
but that was rude and stupid and that
was the petulant younger more brash
version of me these days I've become
sort of a master at evading meetings
that suck up time the reality is time is
all you have in this world and when
you're young you're seeking out
opportunities so you look forward to
serendipity you're taking new meetings
dynamics energizing you meeting people
as you get older you have too much
opportunity you're too many people you
have too much family obligations you're
too many things to do too many places
you could be and then you just end a
busy busy busy busy busy and busy is the
is the death of productivity and
happiness Derek Siver's who I think Tim
had a great podcast with said you know
I'm not gonna say yes or no I'm gonna
say hell yes or no like basically unless
I'm really excited about something I'm
not gonna do it I think that's a good
heuristic to try out and you know so
what if it offends people you have a
very short life on this earth you have
to spend it being happy and doing what
is productive and what matters with the
people closest to you and I think all
the great nests and life comes from all
the great outcomes and let come from
compound interest whether it's in
investing or whether it's in
relationships so like my most popular
tweet of all time is this one that kind
of glib but it says if you can't see
yourself working with somebody for life
don't work with them for a day now of
course you're not gonna like say no I'm
not gonna work with you because I'm not
working with you for the rest of my life
but it's a good reminder that if you
knew that any relationship is short-term
or temporary it's really not gonna pay
all the dividends that you want later in
life so it's better to just kind of
treat a lot of your time as a search
function where you're searching for
through the set of jobs you're searching
through the set of dates and spouses
you're searching through the set of
friends you're searching through the set
of hobbies until you find things you
love and when you find things and people
that you love you go all-in on them so
when you find the person that you love
being around 24/7 and if they're
attractive and of the opposite sex you
marry them if there's you know friends
that you just never get tired of hanging
around with well those are gonna be the
three four or five friends that you
spend most your rest of your life with
hopefully there are happy people because
it'll rub off on you
there's a theory called the five
theory where you can in zoology you can
predict the mood behavior patterns of
any chimp by which five chimps they hang
out the most with so choose your five
chimps carefully so I would say yes
people can get offended making damaged
relationships if you blow them off or if
your non-responsive but you have very
little room in your life long term for
real relationships so guard that time
and it's really it's actually really
important to have empty space if you
don't have a day or two days a week in
your calendar where you're not always in
meetings and you're not always busy then
you're not gonna be able to think you're
not know that have good ideas for your
business you're not going to have good
judgments so I also encourage taking at
least one day a week preferably two
because if you budget two you'll end up
with one a day a week where you have
nothing on your calendar and you just
have time to think it's only after
you're a board that you're gonna have
the great ideas it's never going to be
when you're stressed or busy or running
around or rushed so make the time the
same way with people you need to have
space in your life where you're not
booked with the people that you already
know so this way once in a blue moon an
invitation will come along and a person
will come into your life that's suddenly
really interesting and now you'll be
able to make the time for them so I
think you have to be pretty ruthless
about saying no to things about turning
people down and leaving room in your
life for serendipity and and in my
experience normally if you don't make
time for people when they're requesting
time for you yes it's a little painful
it's a little socially awkward but the
people aren't going to disrespect you if
anything they want to hang out with even
more because they realize you're very
discriminating with your time but guard
your time forget the money I mean money
is actually the least important thing
there's a discount rate to money I like
asking my friends which is okay if you
could keep your friends and family and
you keep everything you know but you
lost all your money and your job and you
had to start over but in exchange you
get to be younger you get to be
physically younger how many years of
your life would you have to get back in
exchange for giving up everything you've
earned and put away
and I have friends who say you know 5
years or 10 years for me personally it's
about 2 to 3 years I'd start over with
everything he gave me back two or three
years of youth frankly but the older you
get the smaller that number gets when
you're on your deathbed when you're in
your last days you'd gave up every
dollar at the bank for another week
another few days another hour another
minute so money has a very steep
discount rate as you get older and you
just realize you get older that it
matters less and less and less outside
of course outside the bare necessities
which you know unfortunately most the
world is still struggling with but the
fact that you can probably listen to
this podcast on an iPhone or whatever
you're listening to it on means you're
already better off than a lot of people
so guard your time it's all you have a
gv8
asks what has been the best lesson that
investing has taught you what investing
has taught me is humility it has taught
me that nobody knows anything I think so
many companies are gonna be great so if
you actually work out it shows how much
luck there is involved and in the system
so it's important is to set up a system
for yourself Scott Adams actually has a
great book on this I think it's called
like how to fail that I've had to
succeed Without Really Trying or how to
fail that everything is still succeed I
forget the exact name which you can look
it up you can go to a blog that Dilbert
calm or just Google Scott Adams look at
his books but he has a great book that
talks about how you should have systems
in life and you should look for patterns
and that way you are not bound to any
specific outcome if you have a system
eventually given all the randomness in
the world the system will eventually
pull signal out of the noise it will
overwhelm the randomness and let you get
to your goal but you have to have a
system because the world is really
random no individual investments gonna
work out no individual persons can be
the perfect one no individual situation
is going to be a huge breakthrough in
fact there's another great saying that I
love which basically the per gate
principle that says that bad news come
suddenly but good news takes time so the
good things in your life develops slowly
over time because you have systems and
nets out there to catch them but bad
things like someone you know had a heart
attack or you lost you you know the
stock market crashed you lost a bunch of
money that kind of stuff tends to have
very very suddenly see this new patient
not get too caught up it's not the end
of the world that something bad happens
and you have a systems for good things
which systems and habits are actually
very related I'm gonna have to get off
this podcast and give the pulpit back to
Tim so thank you all for listening thank
you for inviting me back a second time I
hope it was useful and not just the you
know ramblings of a strange person and I
hope to see you all on Twitter or
otherwise good luck to everyone in their
lives I wish you happiness I wish you
health I wish you consciousness I wish
you fulfillment I wish that this year
you add a good habit maybe you even
break a bad habit and don't take
anything too seriously thanks everyone
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out it's
tasty but more important it will help
you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional plantings for me just covers
the bases takes a load off my mind
puts a lot in my body and check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthtrack
so the question is why why is it so
popular why is it unique because you can
get services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's why the value
of wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally Hart great investing is a
marathon not a sprint
and little thing
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront Inc is
an SEC registered investment advisor
investing in securities involves risks
and there is the possibility of losing
money past performance is no guarantee
of future results please visit wealth
front comm to read their full disclosure
so check it out guys this is one of the
hottest most innovative companies coming
out of Silicon Valley and they're
killing it they've become massively
popular just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront comm forward slash tip
and until next time thank you for
listening